let's talk about mango people let's talk
about your experience working with
President Trump and how that was and how
you think he's doing right now with all
the polls what's out there uh what's
your experience been with him that's
what everybody wants to know doesn't
matter where I am in the country what
the topic is they've asked me to speak
on sooner or later in the Q a the
question is what's he really like and
the fact is if you've been a you know
alive for the last 40 years if you've
watched television if you've seen you
know president Trump the nice thing
about him and I live in DC and it's full
of snakes and Janna's faced you know
lies what you see is what you get when
it's just the two of you in the Oval
Office it's exactly the same as if he's
in front of 60 000 people in the stadium
exactly the same and and let me let me
tell you a story about that first
meeting in Trump Tower in in the summer
of 15.
you've got to understand I grew up in
the UK so Step Up step off upper lip
debating Club you know all very proper
blah blah blah and I walk into this kid
from Queen's office and the Donald's a
little bit different he's not exactly
from you know uh private school in West
London like I was
so I got a little bit of getting used to
but within three minutes of talking to
this guy I realize one thing
he hates political correctness and he
loves America and I said
you want me to work for you fine you
hate political correctness
number one number two you love America
you think about you know I was there
when he announced in Mar-A-Lago for the
second time
and of course I was there to You Know
cover it for my show and to you know
support him but I'm listening to it and
I'm standing there
and it blew my mind because what has he
been put through for the last six years
have your home rated by armed FBI agents
have your wife attacked have your son
attacked being called a anti-semitic
white supremacist when your daughter
converted to Judaism and your grandkids
are Jewish
and you're prepared to step into the
arena again
I salute that I salute that so um a
great American bottom line whether you
like his tweets or not when people say
the tweets seriously six million illegal
immigrants and you're going to talk to
me about tweets I mean grow up will he
just wait before well this is I don't
know the ability tweet that's the big
one the question there's a lot of
questions that's probably the most
important one yeah
um I don't know because of true social I
don't know what what deal he's got with
the investors at truth social whether he
can't we'll see he's got he's got a year
and a half does he follow he's on
Instagram he's using face using
everything right so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign